genius brain listeners before we start
this podcast this podcast is brought to
you by better help mental health is
mental wealth I'll say it a million
times over and you could start with
better help do you ever find that you're
just trying to fall asleep sometimes
your brain suddenly won't stop talking
do your thoughts start racing right
before bed or at other in opportune
moments and it helps or it doesn't help
you sleep at all well it turns out one
great way to make those racing thoughts
go away is to talk them through therapy
gives you a place to do that so you can
get out all of those negative thought
cycles and find some mental and
emotional peace and that's why I love
better help I've been using better help
for quite a while and I have it in my
back pocket whenever I need it so try it
out you have nothing to lose get a break
from your thoughts with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com genius today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com genius genius farts this podcast
is brought to you by mood mood is known
for their ferally legal THC but now
they're adding their most potent product
yet to the lineup introducing hemp based
thca flower the future of legal THC
tried along with all of mood's other
amazing offerings like delta8 flow
gummies Vape cartridges and more my
favorite thing that I get is the
pre-roll stuff I'm not that great at
rolling my own stuff so the pre-rolls
are always the way to go for me and let
me tell you something good little night
cap for me I absolutely love it so try
mood's new thca flour today and for 20%
off your first order at a free gr of
thca flour go to hello.com and use promo
code genius that's
hell.com promo code genius for 20% off
your order and a free gram of thca flour
this podcast is brought to you by haries
my friend no matter why you shave har
has you covered for the best shave of
your life at a price you'll love get
better quality and a better price than
other razors when you get Harry's
delivered right to your door I have been
using haries for quite a while now and I
have the smoothest face ever and guess
what scheduled your deliveries for
refills as low as $2 half of what you
pay for other blades so what are you
waiting for get your best shave ever
this summer with Harry's razors and
skincare products get a $13 starter set
for just $3 at harry's.com genius that's
harry's.com genus for a $3 starter set
today and I'm starting to wonder why
because at this point I'm thinking do
you have nothing in in your life to talk
about except to drag Will Smith through
the dirt yeah that's the only thing
there's only two things that she talks
about Will Smith and Tupac mhm that's it
in 5 4 3 2 one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast we are in a new studio we
have Ryan here once again dude thanks
for having you man sexy [__] man we
have the huge dong Pete in the back big
old [__] on this guy dude swing that
thing baby I'm swinging it it's off
camera but you're seeing it is that like
a known that's his reputation 100% I
actually pushed him in the back earlier
his dick kept him
up
what learn that the first thing you know
about somebody ask him to show you it's
delicious it's delicious like it's tasty
well speaking of dicks Ryan what the
[__] listen listen are we going to eat
dicks yes we are oh my God get out of
here we so you know before when I asked
Ryan to come on the
podcast he was like he was joking around
saying that he was going to bring some
balot I was like well instead of
bringing a duck fetus let me show you a
Korean delicacy now some people don't
like this this is actually one of my
favorite Korean dishes right what is
what's the Korean name for huh edible
dick it's braap
penis this is stupid this is called this
is a dish called Sund Sund is Korean
blood sausage
oh okay I've heard of it yeah this is
actually one of my favorite dishes on
Earth and I'm going to have you try this
you eat this unironically
yes you eat it when no one's looking no
when hey oh [__] but this is actually
one of my favorite [__] dishes so
today by no choice you're going to eat
this oh my God one of my f you know my
favorite uh Filipino dish is Dinan yeah
you like that stuff huh it's my favorite
W that's your number out of everything
we have to
offer [__] blood porridge it's
actually my favorite dish I had you're
blood guy huh yes I am I had it at my
friend Rene's house growing up and I
remember before I ate it they called it
chocolate pudding or chocolate whatever
yeah like choco meat yeah and I'm like
that's disgusting well we tell that to
kids because it's more appetizing and
I'm like yeah I don't think that makes
it more appetizing you don't like that
yeah but that so when I expected it to
be sweet or whatever and I ate it and it
was like vinegary and salty which Korean
people love so I thought it was the best
thing on earth oh and when I go to Maui
there's this restaurant inside of a
motel they it's like a Filipino place
they have like garli they serve it with
garlic rice and the side of din you said
it's in a motel yeah are you sure it's a
restaurant I think it's not just a guy
with a box he's just chewing like bael
nut beut I had that [__] it's disgusting
yeah it's a little and it's everywhere
in China it's in China the Philippines
like Taiwan so I had it in Taiwan and
when I first chewed on it people were
talking about like oh it's like it's the
best yeah they say it's going to like
trip you out or something or make you
feel weird it it it gives like this
electrical pulse to your brain huh it's
it's weird as [__] so I guess a lot of
taxi drivers in Taiwan chew on it to
keep them awake cuz it's just working
247 so their teeth are all stained from
it so they mix the nut with a I think
it's a tobacco leaf and they put like
this powder on it which I think is a
lime powder and that causes a chemical
reaction that makes it red so it stains
their teeth oh but anyways you're GNA
eat this
dick long as it doesn't stain my teeth
we'll see about that my friend is
actually not as crazy as you I'm just
curious to see if you like this all
right why does it have to be wrapped up
like a Dexter
murder like a cab it's like WRA the same
way they would wrap a regular human like
a regular human
body so I want you to grab and this is a
seasoning salt of like kukaru which is
you know Chu yeah got it so I dip this
in here oh man it really feels like a
dick not my dick but you know not my
dick give it give it a go oh
God it's not as crazy as you think it
is it still feels like a dick in your
mouth I'm like when's it going to taste
like meat and feel like meat but I mean
dick is meat so yes I'll pull this back
I'm not going to finish that
[__] man I should should have brought
ballute man I shouldn't have joked too
bad I like it brought I should have
brought a [__] ostrich
ballute and like in my country we got
this thing this this [__] dinosaur
egg now every time I come I'm going to
[__] you and be like you
[__] here we go so this is dog
[__] in Manila people just eat this with
a little line and you just start
squirting it Dam please try this is a
Dalmatian [__] shake this is from Manila
have to believe it either way well you
have to you get cancer dude we were
talking about earlier
where they they had this so if you guys
don't watch JK news or if you do you
most likely if you're a fan of mine you
watch JK news but you guys did this
video for the for the uh promotion of
your guys' shirts and I [__] di all
Joe dude of course it's Joe of course
it's Joe first of all how did you get
this random Indian dude in the random
Village to promote the T-shirt just
kidding news it's not just a just
kidding news just kidding news careful
boys is a brand just kidding news is the
man of smart people the people of just
kiding news careful boys they are very
smart just kiding news the number one
forcast in the world I love just King
news careful Boys in California United
State of
America to promote the best podcast in
the world podcast in the world bro this
dude like I don't one day Joe was just
like yo send me six highdefinition
photos of us and I'm like all right so I
tried really hard to find the best
definition photos only for them to come
back looking like straight up
sandpapered [__] Polaroids but Joe I
guess he just knew about this guy and I
think like he might be famous for this I
think he is yeah I think he is like
everybody knows him it's the [__]
weirdest [__] it's it reminds me of
those old VHS
commercials yeah CU like just getting
best podcast in the world yeah he just
like you pay him to do these like weird
shout out vids and he'll like do
slideshows of your stuff and then
there's just unrelated footage behind it
all like he's in Singapore and then it
just shows him like shaking hands with
like I think techn Viking what the [__]
yeah it's the most random I died [__]
laughing and of course it would be Joe's
idea if Joe could run the promotion of
all of our companies we would be
canceled like that dude it only works on
just kidding news there's no other
company that's would work for yeah he
wants to do that for ji matcha too oh he
does aren't you in charge for the
marketing yeah so you're the only thing
standing in his way
yeah when we were in Hawaii this
will this he'll talk probably talk about
this
podcast [__] he likes sleeping out in
open air so like we get this place that
all of us can sleep in and then I wake
up in the morning and I see this fo
giggling I'm like what happened he goes
bro I was sleeping out on the balcony
and I pissed
self that's full [__] peed in
asleep he's in his
30s I was like wait why were you
sleeping on the balcony there's a bed
for you here he's like I just like
sleeping in the open air and then he
peed himself in his sleep does that did
he pee himself because of sleeping in
the open air is that something only
happens outside I think he did the thing
what happens to you when you're 6 years
old where you have a dream that you pink
that he just pissed himself and so in
the morning he's like washing his
underwear like in the bathtub or some
[__] he's just like well it happened it
is what it is that's [__] Joe man
yeah every time we tell stories about
like we're going to go around and be
like all right everybody tell us your
best [__] story where you [__] your
pants and we all think we're going to
pull from like ages ago it's like Joe's
like last
week he's like last week I should I
sprayed the whole floor like he's I'm
like really dude there was this funny
moment in Jay kenyas where we're all
talking and then years ago I would tell
like these personal stories and every
now and then there's like these trolls
they like oh that story is not real
that's [__] fake and then Joe would
just randomly out of nowhere he goes I
used to sell
piranhas he was a piran plug man and
then Steve stopped he goes he goes I
like how you guys all think David's
stories are fake and this guy out of
nowhere says he sold piranas out of his
garage yeah the [__] are you guys
talking about and him his every one of
his stories sounds like it's it's like
you just freestyle it's like a freestyle
rapper that's losing the audience
exactly oh [__] so I saw
piranhas
what rhes a toata what rhes a Tata it's
just so [__] I'll be telling a story
about all this one time in school I saw
like this fist fight and like fake and
Joe's like dude I [__] the giraffe
nobody questions it yeah that's true
like no one questions it like he was he
was telling us a story about how like
his friend they used to like either they
were selling sparrows or Birds by
shaking them out of trees and catching
them in bags or some [__] Joe's a
crackhead dude he's a legitimate [__]
crackhead he yeah he's like a perfect
definition of like what a latchy kid is
doing you know 100% dude this is what
they're doing when you when there's no
parents around like he'll just stop
he'll literally be like so I remember
when I tried crack yeah like Joe what
the [__] does that have to do with the
state of this country it's pretty crazy
when you think about like as a Asian kid
it's like oh man like if your parents
are not around and you get to act on
every impulse like that's his life like
he got to be caught in the randomst
situations and I always wonder too with
him what was it like raising a kid like
that because he's so even as an adult
he's extremely impulsive right which
blows my [__] mind it it's kind of
crazy when you think about it like
people go oh that's my boss you know
this guy's impulsive as [__] dude you
know what he said the other day he goes
we were talking about social media with
like uh we were with Under the Influence
we're eating like Chinese food at the um
after the shoot and he goes you know
what I think it's time we go on Tik Tok
like as star JK account I'm like I've
been running the Tik Tok account for
like 2
[Laughter]
years doesn't know anything that's going
on with this company he goes oh okay
cool like it's like a checklist thing
like got it done that's my
boss he just he calls you in the middle
of the night hey man it's time for Tik
Tok Joe I've been doing this for two
[__] years he goes really good job HS
up and it has like the most following
out of all our social like short form
that's so funny to not notice and go
like I think it's time we tackled this
Beast I just started doing Tik Tok again
a little more recently Okay and like
this Tik Tok controls everything you you
literally can't say anything negative or
they take your [__] out yeah yeah yeah I
didn't like I kind of knew that but
didn't know how severe it was like I did
this video of this ginormous girl
falling off a cliff and they said that I
was promoting dangerous activities
that's negative I'm not promoting I'm
literally making fun of her for falling
off the cliff
wait which chick fell off the cliff so
this girl she she was about to dive off
is it that white girl that like hits the
side of and she falls in cuz she like
hesitates yeah oh my God and so I'm just
kind of making jokes about it because I
used to cliff dive too and there's a a
video of me cliff diving as well and I'm
fat as [__] right so I'm just making I'm
making fun of myself and they said that
I was promoting dangerous activities to
children and so they they Bann my
content that is so that's really odd
I've had two uh Tik Tok accounts deleted
because of the way oh that's why you're
you're handle is again again this third
[__] time I've opened up God I always
wondered about that I figured that's
probably something that happened yeah so
the first Tik Tok account I didn't
really do much I think because it was
such a hot space people just knew of me
so I had like 200,000 or some followers
on it and then it got deleted just wiped
out opened up another one had 100K Falls
got deleted no appeals or anything no
appeals or nothing because the the the
reason why I got deleted on the second
one it was I was making fun of Lebron
james' hairline oh that's promoting D
activities I know so they deleted my
whole [__] account for bullying I'm
like I'm bullying LeBron James if LeBron
reported you then that's he probably did
he probably did it's full [__]
reading books upside down and [__] dude
bullying it's it always strikes me as
like I find it so weird that Tik tok's
so strict on verbal but like visual like
you got this girl with her freaking
crack out dude I have masturbated so
many times the Tik Tok videos it's
unreal it's so weird this the like the
skew the sea every time I open up my Tik
Tok I don't know if they understand my
mind but it's always a lady with her tit
out and then randomly a baby comes in
but I stop the video at the tit I go
nope you're not you're not stopping me
from jacking that loophole is one of the
craziest ever I've never seen so much
free tits breastfeeding wearing lingerie
yeah what does that had to do with
anything it's like free the breast
women's bodies are beautiful I agree and
then this child comes I'm like get out
of the [__] screen baby this is not
for you this is for me Pete knows dude
that's what Pete jacks off to every
night baby it's so crazy that that
doesn't have any type of flagging at
all's that we got to talk about a Hot
Topic this podcast is brought to you by
Zach doc have you ever been on the hunt
for a new doctor and you ask literally
everyone you know for their wo you know
a doctor who actually gets you listens
to you and makes you feel super
comfortable and finally after weeks of
searching you find the one so you call
their office and they have an
appointment available but then the
reception tells you the perfect daughter
doesn't take your insurance and we have
all been in that situation before well
guess what wipe your tears put away the
ice cream and head over to Zach do to
find and book the Doctor Who is right
for you and takes your insurance this is
so important to me finding a doctor that
gets me I don't want to go through this
whole thing where I find a doctor that
likes me and suddenly they don't take my
insurance and then I'm kind of stuck in
a crappy place that I was before we're
talking about booking appointments with
thousands of top rated patient review
doctors and Specialists you can filter
specifically for ones who take your
insurance and are located near you and
treat almost any condition you're
searching for so go to Zach do.com
genius and download the Zach do app for
free then find and book a toprated
doctor today that's
zocdoc.com
geniusz
do.com genius genius brain listeners
this podcast is brought to you by better
help mental health is mental wealth my
friends so get on it today with better
help I personally love better help
because it helps me go through all of my
thoughts which in turn helps me relax
which helps me have a better night's
sleep because I hate it when my mind is
racing at night cuz I'm pretty sure
you've been in that position where
you're trying to fall asleep but your
brain just won't stop running or working
it's just constant and it turns out one
great way to make those racing thoughts
go away is to talk them through therapy
gives you a place to do that so you can
get out of your negative thought cycles
and find some mental and emotional peace
listen if you haven't tried therapy why
why not try it with better help um I
like the fact how convenient it is it's
entirely online uh designed to be
flexible and is suited to our schedule
all we have to do is fill out a bre
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge and that's what's great about it
it's the convenience and it just can't
be beat so get a break from your
thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com genius today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com slash genius this is a very weird
segue I have no Segways
whatsoever but if you guys
notice babies are bald the babies are
bald so let's talk about jayah P
Smith so listen I've spoken about Jada
pink Smith multiple times on this
podcast right and with this podcast
we've kind of kept it long format where
it's about an hour and a half and I want
to bring this down to about 45 minutes
to 50 minutes because I wanted to be
more specific about the topic cuz every
time I do a podcast or something I want
to talk about but I always get
distracted so I just next thing you know
we don't talk about the actual Hot Topic
until 3 months later I keep on doing
this with movie reviews like every time
I have my buddy Edon we go oh dude yeah
we just watched let's talk about it and
then we go okay we forgot to talk about
it next one and then I do a a movie
review of The Flash eight months later
after the [__] release and then
nobody gives a [__] so this is already
late but we are going to talk about Jada
pinket Smith right and this also just
goes way back from the the infamous Will
Smith slap right which kind of shook
everybody yeah we don't see this type of
behavior from Will Smith right Will
Smith is supposed to be the pure example
of what a man or what a healthy couple
or healthy parent should be and we've
always looked towards this guy as like
the epitome of what mental health is or
whatever so obviously on this award show
Chris Rock starts making jokes lobs up
this very simple very benign joke
neutered yeah yeah it wasn't even that
bad he calls her what GI Jane and then
he goes he goes Jada GI Jane too can't
wait to see it there you go that's the
ex and it was so simple right very
simple yeah it's more funny because it's
so stupid and simple and the deliver is
like exactly and so when I heard that
joke I'm like ah it's a it's a little
quick little joke whatever he's pretty
tame and then will laughs his famous
Infamous Will Smith
laugh he does his Will Smith laugh J
rolls her eyes he looks over he goes oh
she doesn't find it funny keep my wife's
name out your [__] mouth comes up to
Chris Rock and slaps the living [__] out
of him right that whole thing happens
well this goes on obviously brings Will
Smith stocks all the way down now you
would think that this man has been
through enough right but then of course
you have the Bold demon Jada pink and
Smith come out and now she is she is on
a press tour for her book God where once
again she starts revealing things about
her relationship with Will Smith we
should not be privy to at all whatsoever
and starts talking about the incident
and she doesn't do it in a way that
makes will look good at all and I'm
starting to wonder why because at this
point I'm thinking do you have nothing
in in your life to talk about except to
drag Will Smith through the [__] dirt
yeah that's the only thing there's only
two things that she talks about Will
Smith and Tupac mhm that's it that's it
why does she have nothing else to
[__] talk about it absolutely blows
my [__] mind so like the thing is is
like I I I'm starting to wonder why it's
like why do like these celebrities feel
that it's so important that they tell us
everything about their personal lives
but they want privacy at the same time I
don't get it it makes no [__] sense I
know it's it's so weird too that like it
seems like she's just capitalizing on oh
this is what you thought well it's
actually the reverse like every time
yeah every time she Uno reverses it
right at the end well she said that the
biggest thing that she revealed but they
were actually divorced in 2016 that she
was shocked he called her his wife at
the awards show why would you say that
why would you say she goes oh by the way
what I found out too was she says oh
we've been divorced since 2016 and she
goes but not on paper then you're not
divorced [__] you're still together
separated that's there's a term yeah
we're separated we live in separate
homes right that's so weird man I don't
understand why she felt the need to tell
this to people like whatever happened to
like my business is my business
and I don't understand why she has to do
that and then bring all of his [__] into
she goes oh by the way I found it very
weird that he called me his wife when
we've actually been separated and but
then she goes on to say we are in the
healthiest healthiest parts of our lives
right now our relationship is so [__]
healthy what's the point of this [__] I
don't know it feels like it's just so
overly it's like a convoluted plot you
know like it's gone so far and you've
written yourself into a corner so it's
like oh let's just repeat seasons one
through three over and over yeah like
god dude why yeah and like the thing too
about that is I I just never really
understood first of all even with red
table talk right she had that whole
entanglement with August Al yeah I know
why was this important for you to bring
up other than for number one either for
views or to humiliate your husband yeah
what is the actual [__] point of this
and nobody ever actually dragged Jada
appropriately because that dude was
[__] young and he was going through a
bunch of like mental [__] and then she
decides to [__] this guy which is her at
the time was her son's like best friend
or really close friend and everybody is
just like ah whatever because imagine if
it was a guy it would be a completely
different story you take advantage of
this young woman who was going through
like a lot of mental trauma but then she
just doesn't even address it it's just
like oh I just had an entanglement like
an entanglement yeah it just it reminds
me of like when people get so caught up
in like when they discover all the
therapy terms mhm and they just stack
them up to like get a get out of jail
free card I don't know if this is wrong
for me to say this but sometimes when
certain people I cuz listen I go I have
a therapist right I'm I'm going through
therapy all the time especially when I
when I need my therapist give this
[__] a call it's like hey do I
got some [__] to talk about but there
are some people who go to therapy and
they come out worse yeah I and it blows
my mind like one of my biggest pet
peeves is when somebody goes to therapy
and the first thing that they do out of
their session they go let me tell you
what I learned today from my therapist
it's like [__] that's between you and
your therapist I know apply it to your
life to yourself yeah but what they do
is they go to therapy right and once
again better help has been a huge part
of uh our podcast and I still love
better help go to therapy but this
mother these [__] will go to
their therapist they'll hear these
keywords like you said and instead of
applying it first they'll tell somebody
how to live their lives by this
information that they just got from
their therapist yeah and they go oh by
the way what I heard from my therapist
hey shut the [__] up yeah they're
weaponizing it that's all yeah yeah and
this is what she's doing too she like
it's this weird celebrity kind of thing
going on is it hard to find a like when
you're a celebrity and you're that rich
is it really difficult to find a
therapist that's not just going to feed
you the sugar that you want you know
what I mean yeah yeah cuz then I feel
like she would just switch therapists if
they weren't following her her whole
thing Dr Phil that's all they call they
only call Dr Phil here's the problem
you're a bald
[__] you're a stupid bald [__] and I
don't like you I think you're a [__]
idiot keep my divorced wife's
name that's what he should have said
keep my separated wife's name out your
[__] mouth keep Tupac soulmates
name doc I saw this meme that cracked me
up it was a picture of Jada Jada and
will and it says Jada pinket Smith has
reported that she never met Will
Smith that's what it sounds like though
that's literally that's not that
ridiculous cuz she'd be putting twists
on everything it's always as R it's like
oh by the way oh by the way yeah yeah
she also kind of that's the thing too
like I don't really like how she always
brings up Tupac as her kind of I hate
the Tupac thing dude it's like what is
the point of this [__] it sucks cuz he's
not alive he's not here to be like uh
nope the Tupac stuff sucks the most too
because it's like wouldn't that be so
sad for you if you died right and your
legacy you think it's locked and then
your Wikipedia gets updated and then the
last thing is just Jada Jada Jada J J
and you're like your spirit is like what
what the [__] is this [__] I don't know
what's going on in her head though but
she kind of does this thing that I think
a lot of people in metropolitan cities
do it's like once
life when people move to this city
specifically their lingo starts to
change a little bit and so they start
using a lot of this weird existential
talk M right spirituality yeah all this
other stuff that they never used before
but when they come into this city they
feel that they could connect to people
by talking about this pseudo
intellectual bull yeah they turn into
Shaman and [__] yeah yeah and look I've
met a lot of people in my life
specifically in the city and I'm not
making a generalization but I am um a
lot of like pretty models do this when
yeah you you have conversations with
them and they're very sweet by the way
I'm not saying that they're not sweet
people but every time they talk I I with
out fail Vibes
spirituality they always mention these
two words right and they try to have
these Pudo pseudo intellectual
conversations about what's going on in
the world and they want to fix these
problems by Vibes and spirituality and I
want to know where the [__] are you
picking this [__] up from where I don't
get it how the [__] does every single
one of them say the same thing and
that's the [__] that Jada pink Smith is
on yeah she is on that right we are now
in this
area where spiritually we are the most
connected that we've ever been where do
you get this what are you even saying I
don't even know what that [__] means
that's the hard part is that like the
probably the most difficult thing that
you could be blessed to figure out is
how to simplify life in relationships
and this is like what happens when you
go completely the opposite yeah so it's
crazy to me it it reminds me of so
recently A buddy of mine went through a
divorce and this woman reminds me of his
now exy wife she also is
bald that's it the end that's it she's a
baldheaded demon I don't care for this
watch your mouth baldheaded
demon she she's
bald no she she has like
this so she grew up in a church right
and the weird thing about her whole
situation is cuz I've I've known her as
long almost as long as I've known him
right so I'm his friend and I became
acquainted to her by proxy Yeah by proxy
right and I've never liked her and he
knew this and I've always been cordial
with her and very kind just because
that's his wife is she like unkind to
you or is it just she says things that
you're like you can't get on board with
well the first reason why I disliked her
was because the way that she would Cod
switch was so ridiculous it would
irritate the [__] out of me so I get if
if you put plant one black person in
front of her it's the most hilarious
like SNL sketch type of [__] you'll ever
see in your life like she like she would
be talking let's say you and I are
having a conversation right just a whiff
of one black person comes by she goes so
okay let me tell you they would walk by
so what I'm trying to say it would be
like on some [__] like that so she any
black person in the room she would just
quote unquote like sass it up and I
never and it was the most ridiculous
[__] and I hated that stuff right and
look we all code switch to a certain
extent right but she would ham it up so
[__] bad it was ridiculous but that's
not even when they're talking to her
it's like if they're just no it's like a
black person walks by if she senses if
she senses like any black American pres
she'll be like
[__] and like the black dude's like why
are you talking like that like I don't
get it what's going on you know [__]
[__] has she's never been asked
by a black person like anything like
what what are you doing well because
once and look I'm not going to out
anybody put any names out but but like
some of like the black folks like that
are around her they're also like La
folks you know what I'm saying so
they're going to like also Hammond up
around her right and I they meet in the
middle all the black guys are like hello
Miss how are you and so they see her
she's Asian so they'll be like
hello that's how they
do it's not that she's
American she got the eyes yeah every
time they see her they also [__] Co
switch how are you
these are so crazy oh why you talking
like that like What's Up [__]
what's up [__] it's a code trade
and you're in the middle just going I
hate everybody in this room I know I
[__] hate you and I [__] hate you
guys but Jen pinkin Smith Reminds Me of
her so much because she also started you
know getting into the whole La scene and
she started switching up her lingo
talking about spirituality what whatever
whatnot and she kind of grew up in a
Christian household and she started
blaming her Christian upbringing on her
personal life choices that she made
saying that I was a good Christian girl
and the reason why I chose like these
certain career path was because of my
belief in God and that kind of stunted
my growth in my career and like the
weird part about that conversation was
like I know you you weren't that great
of a Christian you were smoking you were
getting drunk you're getting smashed
over here sucking dick and [__] the [__]
are you talking about so it's kind of
crazy how people can create this [__]
narrative and victimize themselves like
oh my love for God help me back my love
for God my love for
God yeah oh I love this
Su selective memory though for sure dude
dude we would be in situations where
we're talking to this girl and how she
recollects what happens is very
different from the rest of us I mean
there's a whole bunch of other stuff
that happened too that kind of I don't
even want to get into but she reminds me
of that yeah right where they had this
quote unquote Enlightenment and she
feels that everybody's a part of this
Enlightenment but we're still based in
reality and we're looking at this person
like they're insane but they literally
don't know and that's the same thing
with Jada pinkin Smith people might look
at her as if she's this Mastermind
manipulative person I don't even think
that I genuinely think this person's
crazy do you think that like now that
we've seen Will Smith do that speech
saying that they're in a really good
place do you think that he enables it
and that he kind of likes it I think
that if I pass him you would see a
[__] big
[__] I'm kidding I'm
kidding hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey you just keep
trying hey yo hey hey he he just let you
hey hey hey I know you like sitting
there but hey chill yeah because for as
crazy as she is he's not complaining
about it he's kind of like on board with
it in a weird way like they're like
doing a duet yeah it's like they're
Waltzing this whole [__] that's the
thing too like I I really do
Wonder not that it really matters but
you know she's in the business of outing
out all of their personal stuff which
one of the things that I didn't like
that she said in one of her interviews
was yeah when that whole thing happened
I was shocked obviously she mentioned
like I mentioned earlier that they were
divorced since 2 so I don't know why he
decided to call me his wife and then she
goes on to say Chris Rock came up to me
and he was apologizing and then will was
in the corner still mad because Chris
was talking to me why did you it makes
him look like this jealous [__] you
know what I'm saying she keeps just
dragging him constantly and I don't
understand why like why the [__] would
you constantly bring this man up like do
you have nothing going on for yourself
that your only claim to fame is now Will
Smith I thought GI Jaden 2's
coming is that was that not a real promo
well like also
too just to go back what we were talking
about earlier it kind of goes into that
spot of where when some of the most
unhealthiest people mentally love to
tell people how to live their lives
because yeah that's dangerous it's
dangerous as [__] and I see that a lot
on social media you know where even
people that I know they're not friends
but I know them through like periphery
and I know what's going on in their life
and I know what's going on in their
personal marriages and the next thing
they post I love my husband I love my
wife let me tell you guys what keeps it
fresh between us it's like right I know
you why are you posting this you know
what I'm saying like what's the point of
this [__] maintaining that image and
they they feel like they have to or
maybe what I'm starting to think is that
they are projecting the life that they
want to live right yeah like they're
trying to speak it into like
affirmations and stuff trying to make it
exist yeah it doesn't work that way man
I've been trying it my whole life it
doesn't I've never experienced that way
no way million dollars million dollars
million dollars she just makes you look
crazy yeah still poor especially in a
relationship like that's a whole other
human like you can't just make them else
dude 100% And so you know genius brain
listeners this podcast is brought to you
by mood what is mood you ask well mood
is known for their ferally legal THC but
now they're adding their most potent
product yet to the lineup introducing
hemp-based thca flow the future of legal
THC try it along with all of mood's
other amazing offerings like Delta 8
flower gummies Vape cartridges and a
whole bunch more and for a limited time
mood is giving our listen a free gram of
thca flour and 20% off your first order
just visit hello.com and use our code
genius and let me tell you something man
uh I'm not sure if this is going to work
for you guys this way but I've had had
trouble sleeping my whole life so I just
take a couple of mood products helps me
to relax and chill gets rid of my
anxiety that's what it does for me and
it helps me sleep and I've had some of
the best sleeps of my life after using
mood products it's pretty freaking good
try it out let me know what you think
and you guys already know
David So endorses it might be a pretty
good thing so try mood's new thca flower
today and for 20% off your first order
and a free gram of thca flour go to
hello.com and use promo code genius
that's hello M
o.com promo code genius for 20% off your
first order and a free gram of thca
flour genius brain genius fart listeners
this podcast is brought to you by Harry
no matter why you shave Harry's has you
covered for the best shave of your life
from their legendary highquality raes to
skin products like exfoliating face wash
and Hydrating Lotion Harry's gives you a
premium shavee without the premium price
tag and that's the reason why I love
them so much you know I'm Asian and I
can't get enough of Great Value at a
great deal and most of the time when you
get a great deal you don't get Great
Value but that is not Harry's this is
what they're all about the starter set
is a $13 value for just $3 at Harry's /
genius so what are you waiting for it
includes a five blade German engineered
razor weighted handle foaming shave gel
and a travel cover scheduled your
deliveries for refills as low as $2 half
of what you pay for other blades this is
an amazing deal if you already have
razor you're already shaving then why
not go with Harry's get it today so get
a $13 starter set for just $3 at
harry's.com genius that's harry's.com
genius for a $3 starter set today people
too get so shocked and I I will always
say this and you really do have to
understand this if you guys are out in
like the social media world and you you
you watch your phone all the time take
this stuff for what it is as just
entertainment yeah yeah yeah don't take
it as life advice they are not your
therapist they are not your spiritual
[__] guidance they are simply posting
content because they have to yeah right
it's the way that they stay relevant
it's the way that they pay their bills
and that's really just all that it is
I'm not saying that I fall into that
category as well but there's a reason
why I don't post as often as everybody
else like when a video does well you
don't see me post another video the next
day and another video the next day cuz I
don't care right I I don't [__] care
welcome to part 27 of ching chong
lingong Ting Tong yo what's up we're
here on UCLA trying to find her I know
it's one and done dude it's one and done
and I enjoy the process of it and then I
move on I don't necessarily know if
that's a great idea if you're trying to
make a business out of this but once
again for my mental sanity I can't hang
on to like and comments I just can't
because then it's just a rat race yeah
right I'm just waking up the next day oh
what else can I do to make somebody oh
this wasn't that funny let me delete
this video no if I thought it was funny
I'm keeping it up it just it just is
what it is it helps but so and look when
I first started in this space obviously
a video blew up I just you know I
decided to post content weekly which was
a you know it was intent that was my
intent to make sure that I make
something out of this yeah but sometimes
when people meet their quote quote
Heroes they're like oh you're not the
person that I thought you were well
guess what you don't know these people
yeah yeah yeah that's fair yeah right
you actually don't know these people and
sometimes you kind of set yourself up
for disappointment because like when
they meet somebody who plays a superhero
on on the screen it's like you can't
[__] climb walls this is [__] lie
stop talking about simu
bro you already did that video dog dog
my bad dog hey say his name correctly
it's Seaman
Lube all right don't you disrespect that
way man are we supposed to feel bad for
Will Smith so that's the question that I
have like you know like with Jada doing
all this [__] it is crazy and it is like
unfortunate but are we supposed to feel
sorry for him or are we supposed to be
like bro this is like kind of your thing
like you like this you know like when
you see those like this is a bad example
but like sometimes you see these Latin
couples that fight every day and they
like kill each other but then they come
back together at the end of the day and
they're like so passionate it's like is
this one of those things but just the
celebrity version yeah yeah yeah yeah
like oh oh There was a a a dude he's so
[__] weird but he's somebody who made
a living off of streaming uh NBA 2K and
there was a video that he posted they
have like a Family Channel Family
Channel um and he's Rich As [__] cuz he
Mak so much money off of streaming and
then she deleted his NBA 2K account and
he freaks out and he's screaming he
smashes [__] starts breaking [__] I'm
done with you get the [__] out of my
life or whatever and people are reaming
this girl right rightfully so but at the
same time you don't think that they're
doing this on purpose yeah you don't
think that this thing didn't go viral
and then people are going to start
chiming in and putting into the chat you
should leave or B but guess what happens
they're still together I wonder why
because it's Cloud save EXA doesn't
nothing happens exactly it's it's the
dumbest thing on earth right and so
people chime in they write all these
comments this is what you call toxic
femininity blah blah blah you shouldn't
be with her you guys are all getting
[__] played how do you not understand
this [__] do you think that this woman
this house that he paid for through this
she's going to delete it yeah which is
great for entertainment just like Jada
you know like for that if you're just
entertained by it that's cool but if
you're applying it to your mistakes and
being like Oh I was in an entanglement
too see it's like bro that's not going
to be a good road at all yeah and look I
I'm I'm going to keep harping about this
as we continue to do these podcasts over
and over I just watch the stuff for
entertainment it's not life advice at
all I may say things that are
suggestions you don't have to apply it
if you take something positive from this
that's great but look you might even
meet me in person or you might meet Ryan
in person and be like hey this guy's
trash you know we not might we might not
be the people that you thought we were
so don't stop Asian hate is what you're
saying yes continue Asian hate dude I
want whenever you see a slan eyed go out
there I want you to start throwing
elbows and fist
100% dude start with Seaman Loop I'm
kidding I'm kidding I like him you know
I make fun of him so much only because
it bothers him and it's just it's like a
bully side of me and I really yeah it's
like that thing where you can't resist
when you see like somebody react you're
like oo this is a good Target I know I'm
going to keep on doing it yeah but
blessings to him blessings blessings
blessings spiritual energy spiritual
energy and uh blessings right blessings
blessings blessings your head is huge
huge it's gigantic it doesn't make sense
for your body size your legs are really
short blessings oh
no I just look it's just you guys have
to stop egging me on all right the more
you egg me on the more I want to do this
I have no personal Vendetta against this
man it's just it's funny because I know
that it bothers him and I just keep
doing it more and more and more look I
get made fun of all the time too you
know for quite a long time I didn't wear
this jacket because of one comment
somebody wrote this comment what's the
comment on that ha it was this one
comment that made me die laughing and it
made me a little self-conscious they go
and it was my fault because I engaged in
this right somebody wrote this one
comment and it wasn't a bad comment they
go damn David I didn't know like [__]
was so tough for you out there and I
wrote back I was like LOL why do you
think that they go like cuz I didn't
know you were delivering Domino's Pizzas
for a living
damn
damn this [__] roasted the [__]
out of me I like that he waged that you
would say something I know cuz it sound
like he was concerned oh my God he
sounded so concerned I was like what do
you mean and he was like good roast this
fo made me I I cracked up so [__]
hard and then my feelings were a little
hurt and I didn't wear the jacket for
the longest
time now it's out of retirement and now
I'm wearing it cuz I don't [__]
care I don't [__] care okay that's a
good one that was so [__] some the
biggest Trend right now on Instagram is
for is to read comments people are just
oh dude yeah vicious dude I Michael
Black's like the king of that dude he's
the king of receiving his roast so well
man dude I saw every time I see a video
of something ridiculous I just go into
the comments and it's the funniest
[__] comments I've ever read in my
life and I'm just thinking to myself
like I can laugh at these jokes because
I'm not making it yeah and a lot of
these guys aren't celebrities they're
just funny people they're just regular
ass people that just said something
great they just they make fun of people
so much like there was um
there was a girl who was a larger girl
yeah right she's showing her outfit
she's wearing this baby blue dress she
comes up she goes I just want to say
people I [__] slayed and then I'm
like I wonder what the comments are
going to say and then the first thing
that pops up is like this girl wore a
bed sheet and said she slay and I'm like
that's [__] up hilarious iing all the
comments like like like like like like
we shouldn't be enabling this man it's
so good my algorithm is all [__] up
yeah dude cuz I keep liking all the [__]
that I shouldn't [__] like and I if
you look at my algorithm it's all mu
Thai and just [__] fat people and
people with
Autism like it's like autism and down
syndrome people that the algorithm
serves people that are into autism and
down so like the biggest thing right now
is hot people with Down Syndrome okay
because of like the reality shows that
are coming out I think so but there was
this dude that was on and he was like I
I think he's like you know when you have
Down syndrome you kind of all look the
same same ethnicity but I think he's
like it's God's will that's not mine and
so he's kind of attractive yeah and so
he's like dancing he's like body rolling
she got this like tight ass v-neck and
then the first comment says God nuked
this guy for a
reason oh and there was another where
this girl is really pretty she has like
these green eyes and then somebody wrote
I'm down if you're down my favorite
comment this bad this girl don't got
down syndrome she got damn syndrome
dude see that's why I like there's like
downsides to like the internet having
anonymity but I like that these people
don't have to worry about their lives
like they can say whatever the [__] they
want dog these I was like damn even I
can't think of a joke like that that
[__] is so good it's cuz we spent too
many years stopping ourselves from
saying [__] that bad hey and I've said
this on this
podcast during pandemic everybody
straight up nuked comedy when you swing
the pendulum this far here guess what
it's going to come right back and people
got tired of telling others like you
can't make jokes you can't make fun of
people like that yeah which I think is
absolutely stupid so if you're saying
one group of people can't get made fun
of then who does it apply to who who who
gets to decide I know when everybody
gets made fun of equally that's when
things become Fair people just tried to
tell people what they can't or couldn't
say and then people just got tired of it
because nothing became funny anymore
like we cannot make fun of people yo
when people roast me and it's not like
attacking me and it's just jokes I leave
it up there and I [__] like it that's
great cuz it's so [__] funny that
Domino's joke stuck with me just like
this other joke I mentioned this a
million times of this podcast when my
when I can't grow sideburns so my friend
said I had Japanese [__] hair for
sideburns you can't goow sideburns I
can't this is like I can't grow
sideburns and so one day my buddy David
looked at me he goes this F got Japanese
[__] hair on the side of his head and
that [__] hurt my feelings so bad this
fo told me that he has to pixelate the
side of my head when I walk by oh
[__] dude but you grew up around so much
roasting it's hard for me to imagine
that anybody in comments today would
even beat what your probably Hometown
friends have done and in in person to a
bunch of people laughing at you you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah and everyone's
waiting for you to say something too
exactly they would call me hentai head
so
like that [__] you know how hard that is
in high school that's hard cuz now it's
like you can take your time type it
backp N I don't like that you can take
your time and then and then respond
tomorrow 100% And so like you know that
roasting culture really is dope sometime
it gets exhausting cuz people don't know
when to do it and when not to yeah it's
hard the intention behind it is
everything like if someone's roasting
you to put themselves up in front of a
girl they like that's not funny that's
weird as [__] that's funny that's that's
kind of strange yeah there's like a
rhythm to it right and then also too you
roast people who you know who can take
it and if you dish it out you have to be
able to take it too that's the main
that's the Golden Rule and a lot of
people don't do that so they'll make fun
of somebody and then then they get made
fun of back they get all pissy about it
it's like dude you don't get to dictate
what happens after you set the tone yeah
so now you have to accept it yeah you
entered the ring man like and I feel
like for me a lot of guys that I was
around they kind of just always roasted
each other all the time yeah and so I
kind of got numb to it and then I also
started to realize too if I'm around
other Comics I also have to put on a
different brain so sometimes I'll go
back home you know my friends aren't you
know funny people yeah and then I'll
just be [__] making wild ass jokes
and everybody's just dead quiet and
they're like what the [__] I'm oh that's
right you guys aren't in this world and
I'm saying wild that [__] so half the
room is like mortified and the other
one's like laughing their ass off and
I'm like oh [__] that's right this is
different it always happens with Jason
chenny so Jason chenny cuz we roast each
other all the time and so so I get into
this roast mode and then I'll talk to my
wife like I talk to him yeah and it's
just a bad night it's like oh oh right
right okay I see what you mean now you
know mean the tone is so different yeah
yeah yeah especially if you like meet up
with him in the morning or some [__]
your whole day is [__] this will Jason
always be roasting me out of [__]
nowhere dude all the time that's like
our relationship so with him I always
have to realize okay this is like the me
chasing and Pat conversation and then
afterwards when you talk to normal
people don't talk about down Tik Tok
that's a dangerous group chat to be in
oh a the our group chat you Pat Pat
Riley it's crazy and J Jason chenny yeah
that's we have like our well our group
chat I call it the tards and so we just
kind of like just oh my God we just
cycle roast each other the [__] out of
each other and it's fun and I feel free
like we could say whatever the [__] that
we want and there's no judgment cuz we
all know that we're joking around
Jason's such an unconventional roaster
too yes he picks the path left traveled
every time and it catches you so off
guard he's [__] funny man I don't
think people understand to obviously he
works at his comedy but he does have
this weird natural talent to make
anything absolutely funny dude yeah and
to me he's probably one of the better
Comics that I've seen in a very very for
my taste anyways in a very long time and
I wouldn't be surprised like in the next
two years he's going to have that
Netflix special he's going to be all
over the world dude absolutely have you
ever said that to him personally or you
just say it about him when he's not oh I
refus to compliment him in person you
absolutely out of your mind dude called
this full of idiot every time I look I'm
you're [__] dumb you're not going to
become anything dude [__] trash bag
the [__] out of my face and then behind
behind his back I'm like dude this guy
is cuz that was like the f I think one
of the first thing you told us about him
and then when I met him I was like oh
dude you must be good because uh David
so like said you're the best and he
loves you and he was he looked like I
was making that up like I look like I
lied
yeah like this R guy suck [__] in my
dick man David David
so he's very nice yeah okay okay about
the same David D he looked like he
didn't believe me at all like I
fabricated that like Jason has trust
issues though Jason if you say anything
nice to him he goes why you say
that wh why why you say nice things what
do you want from me dude he has such he
has crazy trust issues dude yeah Pete
what what time are we at right now uh 51
minutes 51 minutes let's wrap it up baby
right on well guys this wraps up this
episode of The Genius brain podcast Ryan
plug all your [__] uh rhan Graham on
Instagram and uh that's pretty much it I
don't really have anything else all
right by the careful boy teas oh yes by
the careful boy teas uh that that uh
link will be on the just kidding news
Instagram right at the top uh thanks for
supporting thanks for supporting genius
brain every Sundays at 12 p M uh secret
s just launched our new our first
[__] launch of this year because of
so many complications but you guys could
check that out in the links that's s c r
TS o c i e t y if you're around anywhere
you see a ji matcha go ahead and drink
that [__] up and we'll see you all next
time peace